[Music]
the snowman so the snowman is a movie
based on a book that people love I guess
which is fine cuz apparently a lot of
crappy movies are based off books of
people like Michael Fassbender plays a
detective named Harry Hole whose life
through elementary school in high school
must have sucked probably the police
academy also because he is named Harry
Hall how many reviewers are gonna talk
[ __ ] about his name probably all of them
how many reviewers are gonna talk [ __ ]
about the movie probably all of them the
gist of the movie is there's someone
who's killing people and leaving a
snowman and he has to find him at least
that's what the trailer told you it was
about in the end this movie is a shoddy
ass messy ass [ __ ] wreck right from
the beginning this set up I was like
alright this is the editing is terrible
totally speaking it's off the editing is
terrible hopefully it picks up about a
half an hour into the movie I checked my
watch so I could actually look you in
the eye and be like yeah half an hour
into this movie I still know nothing
about Michael Fassbender's character and
I know nothing about the precinct in
which he operates in which is a problem
because this is supposed to be a manhunt
movie that's going to revolve around
Michael Fassbender and the precinct in
which he operates in it's like every
transgression a manhunt movie could
commit this movie come in it's Michael
Fassbender plays someone who's drunk and
asleep half the movie which is funny
because I think Michael Fassbender the
actor is also asleep for the majority of
the movie he has no charisma and I don't
mean charisma and I need him to be Han
Solo charming all the checks I'm saying
if this was the first Michael Fassbender
movie I had ever seen him in I'd be like
that guy's going away very soon who
picked him to lead a movie this movie
wants to be three or four different
things it doesn't commit to one it's not
entirely catch the killer manhunt movie
it's part it just look at Michael
Fassbender do [ __ ] like his family
life's also part JK Simmons doing sleazy
[ __ ] himself the movies all over the
place and I'm sure it works in the book
I'm sure the book weaves it all together
to be one concise plot but when adapting
a book to a movie you need to know what
to cut out is we did not know what to
cut out one of the many problems in here
is that there is a disconnect between
the audience and the plot and the
audience and Michael Fassbender's
character Harry Hall someone tells them
in the movie like oh well you're like a
legend we studied your cases back in the
Academy and that's the only reference
that this character is actually so good
at what he does the movie want you to
think he's so good at what he does but
he never shows it and maybe they wanted
him to be this drunk burnout who's super
talented like I don't know a Greg house
or something and addicts
also really good at his job so they kind
of need him to stick around it doesn't
come across that way the only thing that
tells you this guy is that good is that
lady who says hey you're that good see
audience he's that good I mean they
killers mo is he leaves a snowman at
every crime scene but for so long in the
movie you question whether or not
Michael Fassbender's character actually
has pieced together the fact that these
snowmen that are left at the crime
scenes are actually a serial killer
thing happening until he sees one he's
our own he takes action so you're like
alright so you do know that it does the
thing where it gives the audience
information and then the movie assumes
that because the audience knows the
audience then knows that the characters
know just because the movie tells the
audience something is not to say the
characters know we're two very different
things here we never see the characters
piece a B and C together it does these
flashbacks with Val Kilmer's like oh
then that happened back in the day and
there's just so out of place in message
there's actually one part where you're
like oh that is kind of intriguing then
the very next scene the movie does a
flashback for about 10 and a half
seconds and shows you what happened in
that Shack all right well intrigues gone
now I know then Val Kilmer's in this
movie I actually had to Google like was
Val Kilmer sick which I guess Val Kilmer
has had cancer is the internet chatter
anyway of someone who doesn't have his
ear to the ground - Val Kilmer's health
and even the scenes he's talking his
voice is dubbed but the synchronization
in his lips to the words is completely
off at which point if he's sick and he
got a job because he needed a job in the
director or casting director was like
alright we'll give you a job to help you
out I like the facts of people helping
people and again this is me
hypothesizing but just when you watch
the movie just comes across it's like
why is he in it it was a very weird
thing
I hope val kilmer is alright though guys
in the end this movie was a [ __ ]
wreck it was slow but was booked for the
first half of this movie it bores the
[ __ ] out of you
you did literally like pick up do
something it tries to be three or four
different things doesn't land any of it
and then the next half of the movie is
spent you chuckling at the movie plot
and dialogue the movie is full of
awkward ass moments it didn't need to be
in here you see where Fassbender is
drunk passed out on the ground and this
lady gets I'll name it just kind of
grinds on him for a little bit and then
gets off of him if that scene was not in
the movie this movie would have lost a
grind scene strange this is the worst
crime cop movie I have seen in years and
the snowman is in fact [ __ ] hope I
don't get sued by South Park that's not
mr. Hankey all right guys are the
Snowman have you seen it what did you
think about it or what's the worst crime
drama man huh
movie that you've seen whatever it is
whatever you think comment below let me
know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
[Music]